supporters of the liberty and
re-foundation party celebrating in the
honduran capital te gusa gulper
at the swearing-in of their new
president of congress luis redondo
[Applause]
today the deputies of the national
congress have acted opportunity to
protect an action that was intended to
be consummated today to take control by
the criminal structures that have
governed this country they intended to
take control of this legislative power
[Music]
that's because nearby a rival
congressional president was being
confirmed jorge talks
today a majority of 80 out of 128
members elected a new board of directors
and we are respectful of the outcome
the competing ceremonies deepen a split
in the party of siamara castro who's set
to become honduran president on thursday
kalix is a member of her party but he's
supported by a dissident faction who
disagreed with her promise to give the
leadership of the new congress to luis
redondo
he's a member of the honduras salvation
party who helped castro claim victory in
november's election
castro has called on her supporters to
rally against the split throwing the
dissidents out of her party and branded
colleagues a traitor
if we as honduran people continue to
accept these practices
then what would be happening in the
legislature would be to hand control of
the state power back to the dictatorship
[Applause]
the dispute caused chaos in congress on
friday and calix was chosen by the
rebels he's being backed by members of
the national party which has led
honduras for the past 12 years
the punch-up saw the u.s call for all
sides to remain calm and start talks
[Applause]
analysts suggest the division will make
castro's presidency far more challenging
she won last november's election
promising to end the corruption and
violence that hamper economic growth
more than half of hondurans live below
the poverty line forcing many to leave
the country in search of new
opportunities abroad
castro's victory led to hopes of change
in honduras her supporters say that
change is now in jeopardy
alex o'brien al jazeera